i had to do my first frontal actually
this is amazing it's network television
and you did
frontal i mean you couldn't have really
been nude uh well i was and uh you know
i'm not the type of person unless on my
stripper card where i want to be nude
but uh i you know i i don't look in the
mirror when i'm home alone i mean i just
to me it's it's nothing that you i mean
no one wants to see me nude but the
character i play does have a little
freedom with his body and they assured
me that they would pixelate my wiener
now here's the problem um i didn't know
it would only take three pixels
this is the problem with um because
you're a big guy and i'm a good guy but
i was i was cursed i don't know how
you're doing down there no no no they
they don't have enough pixels for me
[Music]
you are blessed
you uh you're a lucky man unfortunately
uh the rabbi who did my work in 1960
um you know the man who performed the
brisk the bris there's something that
you know this first of all i think 1960
was a very free time in america and i
think the rabbi would had a little grip
on the grape because uh he botched up
he botched up area 57 and i could prove
this for years you know the doctors
would but it's it's it's it's really not
a foreskin it's it's like a two skin and
i can tell you why this is
instead of the sweater it looks like a
hoodie
i mean
when i look down there
it's like i stole a bishop
is it really like so small or is it
location look you know is it an optical
illusion because it's on a circus person
on you andy
okay you would go to transfusion right
every time you get an erection it would
be different for you so i figure you
know as an actor okay this guy is naked
because in the pilot i had testicular
cancer right always funny
and uh i lose
uh i lose a testicle and he's he's
coming around and he's learning how to
you know he's in remission and things
are okay and and he's fine but he really
sees himself in the mirror for the first
time and i figured well i would wear a
g-string or something like that and they
said no because you have to be naked
with a
a tiny sock on
oh putting the sock on over the the
you're a member yeah they didn't know
you know so there was
and the wardrobe lady i i was a nervous
wreck the wardrobe ladies where is what
she said she goes
there's nothing to be embarrassed of
i've i've worked on the show hung
this is what she said to me
on hbo which is really what you want to
hear yeah before
before that's my point of comparison now
that i'm working on you yes then you'll
i'm sure you're familiar with my light
switch
so they didn't they had to keep
they had to keep taking the sock up
they you know i mean it didn't it was
for me so we ended up with like you know
those little things that are at the end
of a lamb chop you know those like
little
yeah
yeah yeah okay so it ends up that
they'll go well just put it it was a
small device it was like
you know it was like a rain boot for a
chihuahua
[Laughter]
all right go ahead
so it ended up that when it went into
editing and they had a pixel it
it was such a small air that it looked
like you know there was an accident or
something so they ended up saying we
have to pick some more or they're going
to think
you know i'm b arthur you know what i'm
saying
right
why are you telling everybody this
because i must be up because the torture
no
there's no reason
this is the torture i went through
i had a complete nervous breakdown
and and we filmed this the first day of
the week of the pilot i'm like you know
maybe day three day no we're going to do
it now do it right away yeah and i'm
just like this is you know because it's
a bear and elizabeth perkins who was
very nice because i dropped the towel
there's everything the lord built and
because the way i duct taped the tiny
sock
to the liar
i couldn't even bend over after every
take to pick up my towel because i had
duct taped because i groomed incorrectly
i shaved like if they say man groom
before we
i don't groom i i
you know i don't i don't groom i'm not
asking you any of these questions
[Applause]